avec 22 votes pour et cinq votes blancs
c'est sans surprise en ce dimanche 9
décembre que le conseil municipal de
coignières a élu didier fischer maire de
la ville beaucoup d'émotion sur un
conseil d'installation c'est aux mesures
on mesure les responsabilités qui sont
maintenant les nôtres toute l'équipe
nous sommes en responsabilité là depuis
quelques minutes
sa liste nouvel élan pour coignières
avait remporter la municipale partielle
avec +2 58% des suffrages contre 41%
pour la liste menée par ali bousselham
l'opposition qui prône l'apaisement pour
cette nouvelle ère tout en étant bien
présente
on va laisser le temps au temps mais
nous serons là où nous sommes
nous sommes également représentant d'une
partie de la population et nous
veillerons à ce que tous les canadiens
puissent vivre mieux encore le vivais au
jour la première action pour didier
fischer en tant que nouveau maire sera
de couvrir les écoles aux parents
j'espère que le lundi 17
les parents pourront notamment les
parents de maternelle accompagné leurs
enfants jusqu'aux jusqu'à la porte de la
classe c'est une demande c'est une
demande des parents aujourd'hui pas vous
savez il ya il ya effectivement un plan
vigipirate renforcé mais bon je pense
que l'on peut quand même se permettre
cela aujourd'hui
prochain rendez vous pour l'équipe
municipale le conseil du 18 décembre
pour désigner les délégations des huit
adjoints au maire